this all comes down kalila knows what's
going on you get back home know what's
going on she does music no she didn't
know I'm using she just thinks that I'm
having like that's something going on
and then what happened was um one day
she just says I think I'm gonna leave I
can't be in this I don't know what's
going on what yeah and I told her I
relapsed and then it was just chaos did
she cry or I'm pissed
it was like chaos what the [ __ ] you know
meaning you just had moved into your new
house right yes I'm in this new house
it's it's crazy no furniture it was
crazy and then I go um I don't know
what's going on with me but I have to
finish this game show right so I can and
I will go to some place I don't know
where I want to go Oliver wanted me to
go to the Hoffman Institute so I was
doing research on that but I don't know
but I I knew needed to do something
people I could legitimately feel myself
dying yeah you know I mean I know just
the physical and the mania you know in
the manic episodes and the eating and
sleeping so you imagine now a month and
a half two months in I'm still doing
this game show she's allowing me to use
I go I'm gonna use every [ __ ] day but
now I have to use regular marijuana
because the gummies is too much and if
you stop now it's like Jack Nicholson
doing coke and we'll just stop his heart
maybe I don't know it would probably
upset you because you're now you're drug
addict yeah but I'm stroking now 24
hours a day Jesus like I would do 300
400 hits are you able to be I know I
don't know why my mind went there are
you able to perform do you have sex with
us during the song on my dick is broken
but you're not even thinking of sex
you're not even involved in sex right no
she stays with you she's like yeah she's
barely hanging on but if you didn't tell
her at that moment be honest with her
she was gone yeah but also I was more
concerned that we were more concerned
about like me I lost 25 pounds in a
month and a half because I couldn't eat
and it could barely walk because I have
no energy and
and so we're more concerned about like
my livelihood and being alive isn't the
right word likely I don't know and so
one day I am run into a friend of ours
and she's like you look like [ __ ] and
then she's like and I she's like you
gotta see a therapist
you see my therapist and I didn't know
what to do and I know why I said yes but
I'll see your [ __ ] therapist but she
was a trauma therapist um and he was
Beverly and I wouldn't saw her and the
miracle happened